[Music]
[Music]
Silent Hill it's a game series that has
captivated me since my childhood
childhood you say yes I among many
others were way too young when we were
first exposed to these games I think I
was around the age of 12 and back then I
didn't own a Playstation myself me and
my younger cousin were Nintendo boys but
occasionally the two of us would stay
over at another cousins house who lived
far away together the three of us would
play games on his PlayStation which
granted me the opportunity to experience
games that under normal circumstances I
would not be able to play we finished
Resident Evil one two and three which
were already pretty intense for a
twelve-year-old but then my cousin
pulled out a different game Silent Hill
and it scared us even more than Resident
Evil ever did made by Konami and
published in 1999 the game was
originally intended to be a direct
competitor to Resident Evil but due to
clashing ideas as well as inexperienced
among the development team the game was
shaped into something very different a
more deep and personal experience the
team that developed the game was dubbed
team silent and following the unexpected
success of the first game continued to
make multiple sequels after that I want
to refrain from all the drama
surrounding Konami so long story short
eventually team silent got disbanded and
Silent Hill IP was handed over to
Western developers who would continue
the series onward most Silent Hill fans
agree that the games developed by the
original team silent are the golden
years of Silent Hill and the franchise
has since then degraded in quality hence
for this analysis I'm only focusing on
the first three games from the team
silent era I'm going to exclude Silent
Hill a room
despite also being developed by team
silent it's so fundamentally different
from the others
this video would pretty much double in
size but I might cover it separately in
a future video
[Music]
to someone who is unfamiliar with the
series it's hard to explain exactly why
the Japanese titles are so much better
on the surface level aesthetically some
of the Western made games look rather
similar to their Japanese counterparts
however there was a shift in Soul
unlike Resident Evil which was more
in-your-face Silent Hill was all about
subtlety the smallest of sounds
symbolism and imagery that can be easily
missed if you're not paying attention
the Western developers made the game's a
little bit more action focused and the
monsters became less and less creative
and additionally it also lost a lot of
the symbolism that made the older game
so interesting every monster design
visual clue or music track was put there
for a reason I mentioned in my previous
video that darkness can provide an
additional challenge by disorienting the
player in that regard
welcome to Silent Hill
an area that under normal circumstance
would be pretty straightforward to
navigate suddenly becomes a
claustrophobic maze even in the
overworld you have a very limited field
of view in the original this was
initially implemented to hide some of
the technical shortcomings of the
PlayStation one and in particular the
limited draw distance the town of Silent
Hill which the series is named after is
a pretty big place even in the first
game the streets city blocks and squares
can stretch out quite far so to deal
with this technical limitation fog was
used to mask some of these shortcomings
what this ended up doing however was
create a very oppressive and
claustrophobic atmosphere even when
you're out in the open and actually
became the main staple of Silent Hill as
a far covered town for both the games
and the movie adaptations to come
indoors this is amplified even further
with a field of view of perhaps only a
few meters up until Silent Hill the room
that is where you didn't even have a
flashlight so now let's get into the
level design as there's plenty to go
over when discussing Silent Hill we have
to talk atmosphere first as this is by
far the greatest strength of the series
it's what captivated me in the first
place and made it stand out from any
other game I played previously I have
somewhat of a fascination for old and
abandoned cities and buildings and used
to be quite the urban explorer myself so
if that's your thing then Silent Hill
will definitely strike a chord with you
Silent Hill is a ghost town it's streets
and houses buildings long forgotten and
abandoned you can still find many traces
of former human activity scattered
around the streets and the buildings
newspapers shopping carts garbage bags
furniture and more giving off a very
post-apocalyptic vibe but most of all as
soon as you set foot onto the streets of
Silent Hill a feeling of dread hangs
over you like a dark cloud this isn't
just some regular abandoned town one of
the most prominent ways this is
communicated to the player is through
the use of music and ambience there
doesn't even have to be anything
significant happening visually the audio
says it all
when it comes to silent hill's
foreboding atmosphere the sound design
plays one of the most if not the most
important role the brilliant mind behind
these amazing tracks and ambient Tunes
is sound director Akira Yamaoka who was
present from the very first game and
even continued to compose for the
western made installments all the way up
to 2012 Silent Hill downpour one of the
last remnants of team silent yamaoka
creative experimentation stands out by
the use of very industrial percussive
and weirdly distorted sound design even
going as far as to use the sound of a
dentist's drill during one of the boss
fights the sound of a dentist's drill is
of course already not very pleasant so
this creates a very unnerving feeling
when it comes to the soundtrack itself
there's also a flipside pure silence
Silent Hill knows when to shut up the
sudden absence of music creates a great
contrast when all you hear is your own
footsteps
for some of the ambient noises in the
background the team created a wide
variety of randomized sounds that can
play at any time and at different
intervals keeping the experience unique
even after multiple playthroughs to this
day I still sometimes discover new
sounds I've never heard before combine
all of this with the pitch-black
hallways disturbing imagery and feeling
of isolation and you have the recipe for
a very effective horror experience since
we are primarily talking about dungeon
and level design as opposed to story and
development history behind the games I'm
going to make some comparisons to the
Legend of Zelda series because of its
nature as a fantasy series the temples
and dungeons in those games are for the
most part very quote-unquote videogame
II even if a place is called a temple
shrine or tower it's hard to imagine
that people actually lived here or
visited these locations
whereas Silent Hill being more grounded
in reality it's dungeons are shaped to
resemble locations akin to real-life
schools hospitals theme parks etc I have
no issue calling these locations
dungeons even
though the games nor the fanbase ever
refers to them as such
all the characteristics are there see if
this sounds familiar they are enclosed
spaces separate from the overworld you
can find a map to make your life a lot
easier
there's lock doors keys to collect
puzzles to solve enemies to fight and at
the end of each one there's usually a
boss fight waiting for you these so
called dungeons in Silent Hill are
perhaps less creative in terms of level
design than the ones we encounter in the
Zelda series since they are more
restricted to reality this is however
more fitting for a game of this genre as
a matter of fact one of the weaknesses
of some of the later games is that as
soon as they start to go too crazy with
some of the level designs it starts to
feel out of place
my favorite dungeon area in any of the
early Silent Hill games are the
hospitals one because well hospitals
already creeped me out in real life
amplify that with a decrepit and
abandoned hospital where you can barely
see your hand two inches from your face
because of your dinky little flashlight
and man the result is intoxicating
getting the map to any of these areas is
pretty much crucial unless you already
know the game on the back of your hand
there are loads and loads of doors to
try and different floors to visit it
gets confusing real quick as to which
doors you've already tried and which
rooms you've already checked out on top
of that backtracking to different floors
and rooms you've already visited is
frequently required but with the map at
your disposal things start to get a lot
more convenient and it creates oversight
the protagonist automatically makes
notes of which doors are inaccessible
which ones are locked and other things
of interest I think I would have
preferred to make my own notes but you
know drawing on a map with an analog
stick or god forbid a d-pad isn't really
an option because of the advantage of
the Wii remotes drawing on your map was
actually implemented in Silent Hill
shattered Memories but ironically the
game was so easy this was rarely ever
necessary there is one additional aspect
to the dungeon designs but I will save
that for a later part of the video as it
deserves its own category
[Music]
I've already given you a general
overview of how Silent Hill sets up a
scary atmosphere but what good would
atmosphere be if there's no actual
threats and scares to break the tension
this is of course where enemies come
into play one unique feature that has
been present from the very first game is
the radio
except for Silent Hill the room see what
I mean with this game anyway the radio
is usually obtained very early in the
game and serves as an indicator when
enemies are close as soon as they start
to come in proximity the radio will
start emitting static now you would
think that this ruins the suspense but
actually not that much even if you know
that an enemy is somewhere close you
still won't be able to see it until it's
already in your field of view
the static gets louder the closer the
enemy is and if you still feel like the
radio is ruining your suspense don't
worry you always have the option to turn
it off Silent Hill in general doesn't
feature the greatest variety of enemies
Silent Hill 2 for instance which is
regarded as one of the best in the
series actually only features six
regular enemies not counting bosses but
what they lack in quantity they make up
for in originality as opposed to your
run-of-the-mill typical zombie these
monsters all feature very unique designs
and behaviors monster designer masahito
ito strikes a great balance between
humanoid designs and features that make
it unrecognizable as a human making them
very unnerving the enemy AI is nothing
special but combat isn't exactly the
main focus of the series so much so that
I'm not even devoting a separate
category to it the controls are quite
clunky but this was a conscious decision
by the developers you're not meant to be
a hero or a soldier that just plows its
way through hordes of enemies in fact
it's usually the best option to just
avoid regular enemies as much as
possible and save your ammo for the boss
fights the enemies are mostly there to
contrast the desolate and lonely
atmosphere in between the boss fights
themselves are hit or miss due to these
simplistic and clunky controls it
usually doesn't come down to more than
just run around try not to get hit all
the while you study their attack pattern
to land a few hits in between their
moments of cooldown or vulnerability
aesthetically of course they are once
again very creepy and very unnerving and
in most cases masterfully designed even
if you've never played a single Silent
Hill game there is a good chance that
you will at least recognize this guy
mechanically the bosses are nothing
special but again it's not that type of
game where you have epic boss fights
with crazy stunts involved next I want
to go over the puzzles these are unlike
any of the ones you will find in any
Zelda game no block pushing here folks
these are genuine head scratchers and
some of them are notoriously hard to
figure out it also didn't help that team
silent didn't shy away from putting some
of the most difficult ones in the early
game this piano one right here me and my
cousins must have racked our brains for
several hours before we were finally
able to figure it out
what it comes down to is it's a poem
that describes the tale of birds without
a voice by interpreting the poem
correctly you will be able to figure out
which keys to press in what order this
is easier said than done however as the
poem itself is quite cryptic I'm not
going to give away the solution but this
is one of the earliest puzzles in the
game and I can imagine that a lot of
people got stuck at this point starting
and unfortunately also ending with
Silent Hill 2 & 3
the development team made the games a
little bit more accessible by including
a separate riddle difficulty the higher
the difficulty the less clues and
contexts are given to the player this
way the games can be catered towards
different types of people some might not
enjoy head scratching and cryptic
puzzles that get you stuck for hours
upon end but they do want to challenge
in terms of combat and survival in which
case they can set the action difficulty
to hard and the riddle difficulty to
easy or of course vice versa
unfortunately every main line game after
Silent Hill 3 either had a general
difficulty setting or none at all
[Music]
we are already in the final stretch of
the video and not once have I ever
mentioned the other world or nightmare
world if you will this is one of the
most famous features in the entire
series and define Silent Hill as a town
with a mind of its own but I wanted to
save this one for the end as it impacts
everything we've covered previously in
stark contrast with the fog world as
it's commonly referred to when it's only
dark inside of the buildings in the
other world everything is dark even the
overworld the aesthetics become that of
rust blood and iron the atmosphere
shifts from desolate to hellish
industrial madness enemies are stronger
and more plentiful and this is usually
also where the boss fight takes place in
Silent Hill 2 the Otherworld is a little
less extreme and a bit gloomy er with
somewhat darker cooler colors with more
blues and greens involved the transition
to the Otherworld generally signifies
the halfway point of the dungeon what
this parallel dimension does is
essentially double the size of each
dungeon and yes most of these areas have
a fog world and an Otherworld equivalent
the layout of the area generally stays
the same with some minor differences
however doors that were previously
locked or jammed can now sometimes be
accessible and vice versa in some ways
you could compare this to the dark world
in a Link to the Past a dark reflection
of the light world however the big
difference being that in a Link to the
Past you have control over it in the
light world you are restricted to
portals but in the dark world you have
the option to travel back with the magic
mirror at any time Silent Hill origins
the first game to be developed outside
of Japan experimented with a similar
technique that gives the player the
option to transition to the other world
at will by the use of mirrors in this
case the mirrors are stationary and not
something you can carry with you in the
games from the team silent era you have
no control over which dimension you
visit once you transition to the other
world it takes a while before you return
to the fog world this is not a decision
that is up to you I personally like this
approach to the Otherworld the most as
it creates an oppressive feeling of
something that is out of your control an
external factor or presence that pulls
the strings which is regarded to be the
town of Silent Hill itself when the
choice to transition between dimensions
handed to the player it doesn't have the
same effect anymore it can present some
new puzzle opportunities yes but in my
opinion it's not worth sacrificing that
which makes the game so great in the
first place it's unique and foreboding
atmosphere puzzles based on dimension
shifting and stuff like that is better
reserved for other types of games if
you've never played a Silent Hill game
perhaps you would consider picking one
up sometime if of course you can deal
with the themes of horror if you're
afraid of jump scares don't worry there
are some mild jump scares but they are
very scarce and well spaced out Silent
Hill is all about psychological horror
and doesn't bombard you with obnoxiously
loud sounds and imagery anyway I'm still
hoping for the day that Silent Hill will
return to its glory days we got so close
with PT which was supposed to be a tease
for a brand new Japanese title but alas
it wasn't meant to be but there's always
hope I want to personally thank scribe
for giving me permission to use his
footage from his Let's Plays I know that
some people prefer to watch someone else
play a horror game rather than playing
it themselves in that case I highly
recommend watching his videos he has
playlists of him playing through Silent
Hill 1 2 3 and even some of the western
games he also doesn't just run through
but rather takes his time to explain
some of the lore the development cycle
symbolism and anything else that makes
the game so interesting for next week
I'm looking to see if I can give a shot
at some lore in Zelda yeah that will go
well I also have some other scripts and
ideas floating around so I will make
sure to get on those as quickly as
possible as always if you like my
content Duda that's the thing with the
button and the Bell stuff like that you
know what I'm talking about this is Don
signing off and have a good one
you